in China president Xi Jinping opened his
communist party's Congress in a speech
to more than two thousand delegates the
leader of One party China laid out his
vision for the future of the world's
most populous nation he stressed his
goal of reunifying the self-ruled island
of Taiwan with China
the resolution of the Taiwan issue is a
matter for the Chinese themselves to
decide
we insist on striving for the prospect
of peaceful reunification with the great
sincerity and with the greatest effort
however we are not committed to
abandoning the use of force and we
reserve the option of taking all
necessary measures
foreign was quick to respond to xi's
remarks stating that peace and stability
in the region is the common
responsibility of both sides Chinese
Communist party members are expected to
hand XI a rare third term possibly
strengthening his iron grip on the
biggest global economy after the United
States let's have a quick look at his
rise to power
XI jinping's political Journey has been
epic from political Exile during the
upheavals of the cultural revolution to
becoming the most powerful Chinese
leader since Mao zidong in the 1970s
China has been transformed since the Mao
era from a poor inward looking country
into a global superpower and the world's
second largest economy analysts believe
she goes into the Congress in a strong
position in his appointment for a third
term as party Chief gives him more
political muscle they say the makeup of
Congress has also changed in his favor
there were many factions many struggles
and many disagreements
this is likely going to be the first one
without factional struggles since the
establishment of the Communist Party of
China
which means that Xi Jinping has taken
control of everything
she has taken a Hardline approach to
China's relations with the West
particularly over self-ruled Taiwan she
wants Taiwan to revert to beijing's role
by 2049 the Centenary of the foundation
of the People's Republic he's not ruled
out taking the island by force
his reluctance to condemn Russia's
invasion of Ukraine has antagonized the
West and his efforts to grab territory
in the South China Sea have angered
China's Neighbors
relations with the United States are at
their lowest ebb for years while
tensions between the EU and China could
escalate if she strengthens his
commitment to a confrontational foreign
policy
while the rest of the world is easing
covid-19 restrictions China's
authorities have intensified their
efforts to contain outbreaks with strict
lockdowns Mass testing and lengthy
quarantines this zero covert approach is
one of shi's landmark policies it's also
turning into the most potent test of his
leadership so far at least one person
was arrested in Beijing for hanging a
protest Banner in the city such protest
actions are highly unusual
economic growth under she is suffering
and fears of a global recession
triggered by the war in Ukraine have hit
confidence any hint of China's future
direction will be followed closely
around the world
[Applause]
correspondent Fabian kutchman is
following the party Congress for us in
Beijing Fabian she's remarks regarding
Taiwan let's have a quick focus on that
talking about possible use of force or
not uh calling that taking it off the
table is that just posturing or is this
a true threat that tawan's allies need
to take seriously
well I think the International Community
should take this concerning statement
very seriously definitely I mean um but
let me add some context um I mean the
wording was very strong but it is not
really new I mean there were similar
statements
um also saying that um no measurements
can be ruled out in the in the Taiwan
question so it is not new and most
observers say that
um a war over Taiwan in the next years
is rather unlikely and actually has
become more unlike likely because of the
warned Ukraine because right now the
uncertain uncertainties in in terms of
foreign policy are really very high and
the Chinese leadership with rather risk
or worse but on the long term the risk
is there and I think
um Xi Jinping has made it very clear
also after all what he said today that
he is willing to pay the price in terms
of Economic Consequences and that he
prioritizes his political goals and one
of his core national interests is the
Taiwan question he wants to unify what
he says the motherland with Taiwan I
think the West should take it very
seriously
and you mentioned just now some of his
political interests she is almost
certain to get his third term in office
does that make his power absolute
I mean how absolute his power really is
nobody can say for sure but every
indicator says that his grip on power is
very very firm and clearly he's the most
powerful leader since Mao Zedong that is
also very clear and um yeah also his
third term I mean anything else would be
a sensation so um I'm expecting that is
for sure and what could be possible is
that he would have to make some
concessions or compromises when it comes
to the economy I mean that depends on
who will be the next prime minister and
how much influence he or she will have
but I'm only speculating here the bigger
picture is that Xi Jinping is very firm
when it comes to his grip on power